[Music]
combat talk with the king all right so
we had Jacobs
versus Chavez and that was a hot mess
because your boy Chavez was trying to do
everything in this world not to make
this fight happen you know the fight had
to happen you know because Danny Jacobs
picked this dude all right
sharp has had a name you can see little
things in them but you know the kid
don't have what his father has his
father has that stuff kid don't got that
stuff you know so and when I'm talking
about that stuff I'm talking about that
down deep that dirty that grime grime
the kid don't got it you know sharp in
June you don't have it yeah you know he
has to live up to his pops but then you
know Danny Jacobs goes up to us super
middleweight to fight this dude and um
actually came in a little bit under
Chavez came in overweight and you gotta
say you know the fact that this man
didn't want to take a test you know drug
testing that lets you know a lot of
stuff right there you know and I don't
know whether the word was narcotics or
anything that he's going I can't presume
to to say that I know things or accuse
the man of things but if you don't want
to take a drug test
ie talks for itself alright so then in
the drug test anybody that knows banned
substances and unban substances will
actually show up all right so we have
Danny Jacobs he comes and clean he
actually comes in a little bit
underweight about his body has tightened
he's he's tight he's mentally in a good
place you can see it what we always
worried about with Danny Jacobs is his
chin
you know oh boy has punching power he
has boxing skills but does he have the
chin and you feel shy avenge was coming
in at a cruiserweight size you know boy
it was 180 185 going in that ring and
you could tell he was bigger than him
and he was throwing his punches he's a
bigger man so after a couple of rounds
go past and Danny Jacobs has not been
enough folding not breaking not
disappearing and he's actually giving
you no shove as you know as good as he
gets
because you know Chavez was going to
that body yeah and Danny Jacobs took
that so you have to think what's going
on is Chavez's mine right now we got to
think about the the mental capacity of
the individual that we're talking about
here
the mental capacity of the individual is
going to look for a way out so that
manifests itself later on in the fight
when Danny Jacobs was warming up to it
because he had to get acclimated to that
weight Chavez was carrying a severe
weight over him so he got acclimated to
the weight and he started giving and
taking he started being comfortable in
exchanges and he quote sharp ends at the
bridging his nose at that point and
Chavez decided that um he don't want any
more smoke I don't know if he had a
panic attack it takes a lot to be inside
this ring you know people don't
understand that takes a different
measure of a man it's not anything
that's easy it's not anything that look
that's light and for that man to be in
front of 10,000 fans that actually
showed up for him and for him to quit
and to be sitting under the tutelage of
his father which his father you know his
father don't want to admit it but I saw
his father quit twice quit with Oscar De
La Hoya so I'm trying to quit with sweet
pea you know
in another fight as well so but his boy
had that same problem and [ __ ] instead
of showing our sympathy and empathy this
man felt that uh it was okay to show
that level of disrespect to his son kind
of sucks reminds me of that last Rocky
movie you know my heart goes out to
Chavez any man that walks in that ring
with them gloves on as a warrior and for
you to fold in that manner you have a
lot of personal demons in your life
salute Danny Jacobs for going and
securing that win and uh pushing on to
greater passions he he got rid of his
trainer which I think this is a good
idea because his trainer was actually
holding him back when when Danny is
supposed to be fighting and straining I
had some passively um not moving forward
so Danny had is at a different place in
his life right now and that's that's
necessary all right
Jamel charlo versus Tony Harrison boy
part to that boy Tony Harrison talking
all that mess choking all that crap and
what we have is we have a talent versus
skill right and uh god-given talent you
know god-given talent is a blessing and
if you're able to box with God given
Talent it's a blessing so man Tony
Harrison gotta come up the first fight I
actually thought uh Jamel won be honest
with you but he put him more work not
saying that Tony wasn't you know using
his jab using his right hand using his
distance trying I just thought that uh
Charlo put him more work than he did to
be honest with you so at the end of the
day when it boils down to it you got
Jamal Charles the younger charlo brother
who is isn't as articulate and he
doesn't come off as confident as his
bigger brother and now my mind you
they're twins
alright so we're talking semantics here
we talk in seconds probably minutes
between verbs with these individuals so
when charlo doesn't display the same
mentality as his brother people take
them for you know they take him for the
weaker brother which is not true boys a
knockout artist boy is a complete savage
inside that ring when you step something
between those ropes he gets inside that
split circle
he's a totally different beast he's just
found him Zen in his life he went
through some hard times and he found a
piece in his family he's finally was
ending his life and he's trying to live
their life but what happened was Tony
Harrison caught him slipping at that
point in time honestly I think behind
the scenes they just wanted to create
some type of rivalry and give this man a
loss to reignite that fire they don't
know what happens behind us but it seems
so the first fight you know I thought
Charlo won
Tony Harrison gave a good account of
himself but guess who won who walked out
that room with that Bell Tony did Tony
got that Bell
now now we're looking at the situation
like oh boy buddy you got to run that
back so they set the fight up for the
run back right guess what happened Tony
Harrison fakes the injury everybody in
the industry believes that he fakes
interviews industry believes that he
faked the injuries um I got I got a
report from somebody the insider that it
was all concocted he thought he was
gonna get a fight first before he fights
the champion because the date was
already set
so he figured if I miss this date and he
fights he's not ready for the next fight
not I held him back promoter held him
back you gonna fight that you're gonna
get that run back gonna run that back
all right
so Tony got the fight he got the run
back he has to go do it now what I've
been noticing through this whole
commotion through this whole thing Tony
Harrison has been added a different
level of a whole total level of
disrespect
all right he's trying to provoke Charlo
he's been trying to provoke Charlo to
get this fight taken off the docket he's
been trying to provoke Charlo to a point
that is its it gets physical before the
fight so he can get fined if I can get
postponed and he doesn't have to fight
this man Tony Harrison doesn't really
want to fight charlo that's evident at
the weigh-in at the weigh-in Tony
Harrison actually smacked Carlos hand
you know Charlie was talking to him like
yeah you know just down the third Tony
Harrison smacked his hand boy that's
uncool there's a lot of things that
you're gonna have to pay for but
actually physically thinking that you're
gonna demean a man verbally and
physically he's gonna smack his hand in
they had to give Charlie a hug because
you have to understand with old boy's
brain at his brain his own kill mode
they don't starve didn't got down the
weight that I've been away from their
family and it doesn't take much to set
up man off at this state you know he's
at this point in time he doesn't take uh
a lot to set a man off because he's
ready to fight he knows the fight is
imminent that's all he wants to do I see
this fight going
it probably could go 12 rounds but now I
see Charlie catching them the Charlie
doesn't want to go to the to the judges
Tello was complacent
what Raul needs to do
his use his jab more what he worries
about is landing that powershot and he
was too in love with the powershot he
has to land a jab more set up his
punches and set up that right hand set
up that hook Tony Harrison oh yeah we'll
just stand tall and bought you a taller
man get a load of men pose so you'd be
able to keep him at a distance use that
right hand move their head don't get
caught with nothing reckless and maybe
you might hold on to that belt but my
prediction is this fight as a TKO
Charlo and 10 it's combat talk with the
king catch you guys later this is King
on the run baby got stuff to do happy
winter solstice I want everybody to
reflect uh enjoy yourself this is a
great time see your next fight
[Music]